autre centre opérationnel a reçu un
appel qui mettait en évidence une
pollution sur le lit de la scène aucune
pollution avec un reflet blanchâtre
disparates
le centre opérationnel à mobiliser des
moyens de reconnaissance terrestre
également une embarcation scellé depuis
la scène une équipe spécialisée presque
chimiques et des pollutions nos
opérations d'abord on
ont été orientés sur la recherche
justement de ce point d'origine aussi
caractérisé cette pollution donc on
prend le phénomène est de mettre ensuite
des actions en place
[Musique]
14 km c'est extrêmement grand puisque en
termes de pollution notre notre action
pour aussi de protéger l'environnement
consiste à essayer de canaliser
le plan pour le récupérer le comté or là
compte tenu de la longueur
de l'étendue c'est paul huchon
puisque je vais certainement ses
pulsions un lieu bien avant son notre
alerte
qui nous était impossible de la
canaliser ou de la récupérer
vingt-quatre heures après
malheureusement le courant de la semaine
à déporter cette pollution
nous avions alerté précocément les
services partenaires et les services de
sous pour un poisson du val d'oise et de
leurs les éléments factuels que l'on a
c'est déjà le l'absence de toxicité dans
l'environnement
pour l'homme c'est à dire à proximité
puis ce qu'on appelle détection avec nos
appareils
et d'un mois d'absence des mortalités
piscicoles qui est un signe favorable
et ensuite ce seront les analyse
transmise par la gendarmerie nationale
qui permettront de définir à la qualité
de cette toxicité pour l'environnement
néanmoins ils provenaient en attendre de
ces résultats de formuler des
préconisations à la fois pour la
population et puis également de rassurer
les habitants sur le fait que l'eau
potable n'était pas concerné par cette
pollution et qu'il n'avait pas d'impact
notre proximité